AJ is starting off this hour in
Cincinnati
hey AJ what's up hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve
how can I help and I just have a
question for you my situation is a
little rough so I apologize for starting
out your show on a horrible note but my
husband decided to walk out on her
marriage we couldn't marry for eight
years and this was at Christmastime this
past year and this was all while I was
nine months pregnant with our third baby
he yeah he he still contributing
financially to our bank account however
he is he's basically moved out with his
sister that basically as soon as I got
home from the hospital he was gone
and he is at the point where he's
pushing me to divorce and pretty much
quickly he wants to get his own place
and so he wants to sell our house super
quick and I'm kind of coming with it to
grips with the fact that you know and
I'm a stay-at-home mom so I'm kind of
understanding now I'm at the point where
I'm going to have to become a full-time
worker in my future I'm a believer in
Christ so I know that he holds my future
but I'm scared at the same time and you
know if I find your daughter in the
situation what what do I need to do for
my financial future
I'm so sorry that is scary very scary
yeah so what in the world is he just I
mean we'll gone off the ranch I mean
that's just wild yeah he doesn't really
tell you no I'm assuming it's because
there's another person but he won't
admit that ever and I've also recently
found out that you know he's gotten
himself into a $70,000 gambling debt
that occurred two years ago when I
thought we had been tithing to our
church come to find out we want and he
had been paying about 500 something a
month just to pay that debt and that's
that's kind of so that is that
his name only yes correct okay and what
does he earn a year he just got a new
job where he's making a hundred and five
thousand and I work part-time from home
I make six thousand okay let's first
establish that there that it's a normal
human in your situation will be afraid
and right after that you would be angry
correct okay and then and and then while
you're doing all of that you also have
to stop and set those two things aside
for purposes of negotiating with him
because he's he's a world-class liar and
manipulator because he's a gambling
addict and so I know that I know that
he's an addict because of the amount of
debt and the fact that he was hiding all
of it yeah okay
and so one hundred percent of addicts
and addicts will all shake their head
with me our manipulators and Liars it
goes with the disease okay so you got
understand that's what you're dealing
with and so a friend of mine that does
divorce recovery says divorce turns a
marriage into a business transaction and
so you are in a business partnership
with a person who manipulates lies and
is addicted to gambling mm-hmm you will
not let him listen to me carefully you
will not let him set the terms of this
divorce yeah he is not in control of
this you are right
you're going to take everything for
those kids yeah and I think they're
working because he makes makes the money
the bulk of the income he thinks that
you know he can control it
oh it's the opposite you're about to
control the bulk of his income it's
called child support for three kids one
that was just born the judge is going to
knock the mathematics in the next week
he's not gonna like of this process
I'm telling you can you imagine going
before the judge with a newborn right
and this guy's a gambling addict
I mean can you imagine how bad the judge
is gonna beat the snot out of him okay
so you totally are in a position of
power here
while you're afraid while you're angry
you set those two things aside from a
negotiators perspective you hold all the
cards he's gotten on no pun intended
okay you really got to hear that loud
and clear because child support for
these three kids on a hundred and seven
thousand dollars a year it needs to be
sub free constantia l-- yeah it's a big
deal okay
now what do you guys are on this home
we're currently all about 115 we just
moved in about a year ago so all there's
a home worth I I would I don't even know
to be on Rose it worth five hundred or
two hundred I would say probably two
hundred okay you got a little like what
he then Maui
okay yeah like I said I mean he knows a
lot more than I do so is there anything
in his 401k like fifteen hundred dollars
not much at all like we have barely
anything in savings so how do you have
any other debts car I have I have my car
and he has his car that I I leased my
car so and that's it my name I know it's
in his name good is the other car
exclusively in his name yeah he just
bought it like a week ago
good so the judge is gonna about to give
him two leased cars and you're gonna get
you a beater that you pay cash for you
need car payment right you say you got a
big pile of child support no car payment
no debt except maybe you keep this house
that's a decision we'll think of later
okay right hearing how this was going
what do you think you're gonna do for a
living I that's that's another thing I
have an associates degree so anymore
that was another in office
administration teachers work I work from
home still with the same job at
full-time it's been about four years
what did you make last time you work
full time like thirty thousand okay so
here's the last piece of the equation
then okay yes you're going back to work
yes you're gonna have a big pile of
child support no you're not gonna have
any car payments you're not gonna let
him hand you that
he gets these cars there in his name
there his problem okay
and this is your negotiation and you're
in control believe me you're gonna get
what you want in this negotiation if you
will stand strong because you have the
story to tell and he by the very nature
of this story becomes the bad guy I'm
not trying to beat him up I'm trying to
protect your kids yeah and I got a
$30,000 a year single mom with three
kids on the line that's all I'm
concerned about his welfare is not on my
list of things to worry about right now
okay right and yours either yours either
right yours neither you didn't take him
to race you took their mother for you to
race but you can take this won the race
okay well thank you sir
and listen I want you to go through
Financial Peace University is our gift
we're gonna put you in the class and the
one-year membership so you've got access
to all the videos and I think you're
gonna get a job making forty five on it
you're gonna get a pile of child support
and you're probably gonna be able to
afford to stay in the house that's
questionable right now but you don't
keep the house if you can't afford it
okay sell it and go rent something cheap
and don't let this redefine your whole
life this is just the beginning of the
next chapter of your life kiddo I'm
sorry this is the Dave Ramsey show